Salut.
Donc une vidéo euh je voulais juste
avant de de commencer parler aussi de
pourquoi je veux commencer à faire des
vidéos live genre en ce moment. Euh
je trouve que en ce moment avec
l'événement de Lia Claude Code que
l'ouverture des possibilités est juste
infinie,
ben c'est que il faut que tu crées par
toi-même. On a parlé un peu dans l'autre
vidéo, mais de créer par toi-même des
choses réelles, tu sais. pas juste faire
des du prompt du prompt engineering tout
le temps ton ordi puis ton toutes tes I
tes agents trava c'est le somum de la de
la productivité
quand tu fais des prompt qui guident des
agents qui vont
guider d'autres agent je tu es rendu
haut dans le niveau productivité tu
comprends puis de plus en plus on va
aller vers là tu sais de
prom d'agent qui va euh gérer d'autres
agents. On l' vu, il y a des business
qui se gèrent de A à Z avec des agents.
C'est un agent qui est CEO que lui va
aller guider puis corriger les agents
qui sont CFO, CEO, qui va aller gérer
les agents qui sont directeurs des
ventes, directeur ARH, directeur, tu
sais, qui va aller toutes les gérer.
Puis c'est rendu on est rendu là, tu
sais. Puis de plus en plus, on va passer
des journées à faire du prompt puis à
corriger des erreurs
ou à réitérer des agents puis
tu cris pas vraiment au final. Je pas
toi je oui ta créativité derrière pour
faire les idées tout
mais c'est pas toi qui crée directement
c'est ça que je veux comme retrouver
avec les vidéos.
avec la création de vidéo, c'est de
retrouver un peu le côté humain. Oui, on
est encore derrière un écran
effectivement, mais
je trouve que
au moins c'est quelque chose que je
donne de mon cœur, tu sais. Je veux dire
de de de de ma conscience. C'est moi qui
le crée, tu sais. C'est moi qui le crée.
Je vais essayer justement de
pas utiliser.
En tout cas,
c'est sûr que je vais utiliser des pour
m'aider à trouver des idées, des
concepts de vidéos, tout ça, mais que je
vais pas rester des des scripts.
En même temps, je tellement axé sur la
la productivité que peut-être que je
vais en faire.
Mais euh je veux essayer de garder le
côté humain le côté humain de mes
apprentissages et mes réflexions après
ça reste à voir aussi que ça va évoluer
mais
je trouve ça important
ce que j'allais dire bon pour la vidéo
d'aujourd'hui
en lien toujours avec les cell parler de
pleine conscience ense
euh
je trouve que les ces justement ça peut
rapidement devenir inhumain
dans le sens que
on parle le côté humain derrière on
oublie que
l'autre côté du téléphone l' côté du
courriel l'aut côté du post ou peu
importe il y a un humain derrière
que lui qui a des pensées qui réfléchit
puis qui a des jugements qui a son
quotidien qui roule à 100000 à l'heure
puis euh justement de remettre un peu de
conscience là-dedans dans les cells,
je pense ça peut vraiment te permettre
d'avoir
plus ben un plus de plaisir
à faire tes sales parce que tu
développes des vrais liens humains, tu
dégages la confiance, je dis tu crées
une confiance entre la la relation
puis au final tes relations sont plus le
fun, sont plus plaisantes, tu es plus
toi-même. la personne est plus
elle-même, c'est moins superficiel,
tu sais, rapidement des fois on tombe
dans le robotique, dans le robotique de
j'ai mon j'ai mon rôle, tu as ton rôle
puis on parle en tant que rôle qui se
parle mais au final on oublie qu'on est
des humains derrière.
Je sais pas si c'est clair démonstration
comme ça mais au final on des humains
derrière ces rôles là qui sont abstraits
au final mais au final l'objectif
justement de la pleine conscience de la
méditation c'est de retrouver ce rôle
puis de permettre à personnes aussi de
ne pas être nécessairement juste dans
cette dans ce rôle puis aussi l'humain
derrière
pour que ce soit plus plaisant pour tout
le monde ça soit plus humain puis plus
on enlève les barrières puis les filtres
de ça, c'est sûr que c'est un monde qui
est, tu sais, je dis c'est pas
atteignable à 100 % parce qu'au final,
tu as tout le temps des responsabilités.
entrepreneur, tu as du monde à gérer, tu
penses
tu sais euh retour sur investissement
donc tu as pas le choix
mais d'où la pleine conscience pour en
tout cas du moins pour la personne qui
fait les ces la personne qui fait de la
prospection pour la personne qui va
contacter tout ça de prendre ce moment
là après ça l'autre partie ben tu peux
pas contrôler l'autre personne
si son r tout fa tu te mettes dans la
tête que cette personne
de comprendre cette réalité là que elle
la vie du quotidien dans le roche pu
tout puis de comprendre ça de se mettre
à sa place.
Pourquoi je vais envenir à la pleine
conscience ? C'est que
ça va te permettre d'être plus calme,
d'avoir plus une harmonie dans ta
relation en toême en ton rôle de
l'accepter plus puis de tu fais même
dégager plus de confiance.
Euh
puis aussi jeis que plus que tu es
conscient pendant tes tes tes ces tes
échanges avec les prospects plus tu vas
tu vas pouvoir avoir une créativité qui
va venir en plus
parce que les moments aussi tu es
vraiment tu es vraiment conscient du
rôle que
puis de la tu veux apporter de la valeur
à personne, ben tu vas brainstormer avec
la personne même pendant l'appel.
Par exemple, je donne un exemple de euh
je propose une démo
puis la démo demandé une préparation en
amont. Donc je posais des questions sur
la préparation puis le fait qu'il parle
de ces case à lui pour euh nous autres
qu'on propose
il euh il commençait à à me donner des
choses de qui avait de la difficulté des
problèmes avec qu'est-ce qu'il y avait
eu des anciennes solutions qu' avait eu
ce qui travaill en ce moment avec ses
ingénieurs et tout puis j'is de là je la
relançais puis on construit quelque
chose puis on brainstormait ça
permettait queon crée de la valeur pour
de vrai c'est pas juste on est notre
rôle puis moi j'étais une dév Non, c'est
on essaie de créer la valeur, on essaie
de relancer, on essaie de de l'aider
pour de vrai parce que tu es tu es tu es
tu es impliqué
pour l'aider.
Puis euh c'est ça, c'est pas évident ça
au début. C'est vraiment pas évident de
de faire un avec ton rôle
puis comment tu es en général. Mais avec
l'habitude, moi j'étais encore en
processus de ça. J'étais encore en
processus de
d'apprendre à être moi-même pendant mes
col puis de
vouloir vraiment aider la personne puis
tout le temps parce que ça prend de
l'énergie veux pas. Ça prend l'énergie
de
Ah ben ça ça va être un autre point à
aborder dans une vidéo
de
gérer bien son énergie
mais bon je sais pas si je m'en all avec
Ouais fait ça pour dire
méditer
c'est pas juste pour des mois de
bouddhistes tu sais méditer ça permet
d'être plus performant de mieux
comprendre personnes
puis de offrir du meilleurs résultats
autant à l'entreprise que tu travailles
à tes projets entrepreneuriux que pour
pour les gens que tu cô toi et leur
projet autres tu vas pouvoir mieux les
aider
puis c'est plus important que jamais à
l'ure de d'avoir ce côtélà humain
avec les entrepreneurs qui tu cô toi que
eux ils ont des projets qui ont des
réalités
puis qui ont qui vent 10000 stress en
même temps mais d'avoir ce côté-là
humain présent
c'est je pense un arbre redoutable, un
arbre redoutable pour les prochaines
années qui s'en viennent ou que tout va
extrêmement vite
puis que le monde a besoin de
se retrouver dans un moment
euh
d'échange réel où c'est que on n'est pas
juste dans le superficiel de dans le
superficiel de nos rôles distinctifs de
notre business.
fait que je sais pas si c'est clair, je
sais pas si ça l' de la valeur ce que je
dis en ce moment.
Je sais pas, je sais pas comment que c
vidé un peu un brainstorm de pleire.
D'ailleurs, ça c'est l'apprentissage de
ces vidéos là de scripter mes vidéos. Je
parlais de être humain. Oui, mais
l'humain a besoin de se faire cadrer,
sinon ça donne une vidéo moimême.
Donc ouais,
faire un plan de vidéo,
ça va être l'apprentissage de cette
vidéo là.
Donc ça le titre de ces vidéos là. Euh
moi en en temps réal qui apprend à
qui qui apprend qui doit script ses
vidéos pour faire un plan de vidéo
fait que Yo.